it's a study by Yuri dargov and I love
this puzzle so much now obviously black
has two queens but the king is in
trouble and a lot of you got the first
move right that is simply for the night
to go to C7 and get give a check to the
king and uh the next move is forced
Queen takes Knight
and then comes the critical point you
push the pawn and give a check to the
king and now the king steps forward to
see four square and if you do notice the
king doesn't actually have too many
squares to travel to you can travel to
B3 and can travel to D5 and this is
where things get very very spicy the
queen comes to G8 as many of you saw and
Black's best actually is for the queen
to go to F7 and just give herself away
but that really doesn't save anything
because after Queen takes Queen and once
the queen comes to D5 it's going to be a
winning King and pawn ending for white
but this is the key point and this is
why it gets is basically in my top
top puzzle ever is because black will
actually play Queen to D5 blocking the
check and here comes it's so beautiful
the king will move to C2 black you know
white completely forgets about the queen
and says take it take the queen and so
black says yes thank you very much and
now here it comes the pawn comes to E4
taking away the last square that the
king can go to and just take a look at
those two black queens they cannot do a
single thing to prevent the pawn coming
to B3 and giving a wonderful checkmate